just your everyday struggle monster
reporting for Cutie goodbye I know
you're already gone hi guys my name is
first uh because you know now you know
your life is different now I'm hungover
today went to a friend's going-away
party last night
I flew so close to the Sun and I got
burned today and I'm no stranger to a
hangover make my entire life has become
one long hangover so the concept of
feeling like healthy is very foreign
window consistently healthy lifestyle
and it fit me right in my struggle
monster face there's a look at my
hangover routine busily seemed like a
parody but it's not
isn't that funny my hangover mornings
you just start by me sweating myself to
an aggressive awakening in which all of
my sins from the last few hours just
blanket me like a filthy filthy blanket
there take a quick look at the ambitious
hour that my body has decided to awaken
itself because I didn't set any goddamn
alarm then to make sure I got pants on
then I take a quick look at my swollen
and black and blue pinky wonders
how'd that happen is that broken then I
check to see if my son decided to come
home with me last night
very cool then I click receive my pillow
decide to kick all my makeup off of me
last night very cool then we play the
shame game the damage manage how big of
a guilt quilt did we knit last night and
then we stopped playing because no one
wins this game but then we buy some
shrapnel from the human grenade we were
last night
that means it's time for breakfast then
one of my tips for motivating yourself
when you feel like human garbage go on
youtube and watch people that are just
light-years more capable than you
documenting themselves just doing life
and they're much healthier and better
paced than you here so recently a lot of
special requests fashion videos but
here's the thing and just soak in the
unhealthy comparison of your current
state to theirs then get some
non-judgmental love from your fur baby
who then decides to show you a
metaphorical representation of how you
are to the rest of the world today a
butt hole
but there's no time for art time to look
at the aftermath of the war that was
last night
then we hide the body and we pay our
respects to the thing that we should be
putting in our bodies but instead decide
to continue this parade of dehydration
wait and while our mourning medicine
makes itself we step into the bathroom
to come face to face with our seyh then
we did a quick shower and we wash our
hair until it feel like a beautiful
reborn pile of wet cardboard then we
look at some stupid looking French
bulldogs on Instagram and fill with an
irrational sense of jealousy for their
ability to find simple joy in life then
we head into our closet to get changed
into our work clothes for the day
then we get into our office to get some
power moves going to mix some real work
happen then we look at our inbox and get
immediately overwhelmed and instead
decided to do our makeup so that we
might feel slightly less fat about all
the terrible choices we've made in our
thirty-one years of life I might
continue to make in the future but hey
it's like society pressures us to feel
how can you possibly be unfulfilled if
your eyebrows are filled in and then
whoops
we totally brush take our vitamins today
and then we do some light meditation
just to get ourself centered and using
ten reps all done Real Housewives dawn
so
let go there and my ankle routine if you
guys enjoyed it all give this video a
thumbs up and click this button
subscribe to the YouTube channel because
I'm here to make you feel good by
default look at all the poor choices
that I've made in my life I feel
stronger about your choices you're
welcome
miss you're lovable and capable social
martyr thanks for watching in a way I
don't know
thank other man we're oh it's like all
of the toxins are trying to get out my
body in so many ways I'm sweating my
nose is running my [ __ ] is not in
great shape today